boom
we're live with danielle m ingram hi dan
hey it's great to be here so pumped for
this
oh
wow yeah dan's been crushing it in
synthesizing he he just has he distilled
all of buddhism pretty much into a very
relatable
and straightforward approach and then
you know now he's up to incredible work
with
creating a bridge between science and
spirituality to mainstream
awakening and to make it more relatable
for science to have its
like clinical hands in um
and to funnel more funding towards it
and to change the dsm-5
uh to upgrade it and i'm
i'm in awe at what you're up to right
now i am you're doing it
that's you're living it into being
well thanks it's it's it's exciting work
i'm lucky to be blessed with
an amazing team of people that helped me
with this and are excited about this so
it's actually it's a huge
community effort um it's been
actually there have been so many people
who have been excited about some of
these
science spirituality clinical crossover
projects that it's actually been
incredibly easy
to get people to to sign up and say yes
and start pitching in time
right it's beyond do for it to happen so
it was really just like
helping to light and facilitate and sort
of nurture a spark that really
was just ready to blaze and dry grass
not to you sorry for those of you who
are enduring forest fires and the
burning of the west coast or whatever i
apologize if
that was triggering but uh also but in
terms of like my book synthesizing all
of buddhism no no
no no but my book is like this much of
buddhism buddhism is this huge
vast amazing rich complicated thing
which is why i
actually go out of my way to reference a
lot of other people
who did a lot of other great work to
synthesize other parts of it i really
just
tried to focus on the things that i like
to my eye hadn't been done
quite as well or in the way i would have
done them you know but and focus on core
strengths but really there's
it's been a huge effort to modernize
upgrade translate
um and bring buddhism into
the you know western context so we can
relate to it and it can relate to us
and we come up with something that works
so
yes it's again that's also a huge
collective project as well i'm just
one little part of it but yeah thank you
so let's put science and spirituality
into in the synthesis and all that good
stuff
into a little bit more downstream in our
conversation
and right now let's hone in on like you
just indicated a moment ago
would you say that much of what you
synthesized and distilled
around buddhism was around theravada
buddhism
and then the difference being then
there's also mahamudra or mahayana
vajrayana is that sort of the
distinction that you would make
and then we'll get into what exactly
that is yeah definitely so
i mean actually i'm interested i'm
influenced by a lot of traditions so
if you picked up my book you would find
obviously some pretty strong
terrible influences which i'm you know
make no bones about
i'm very excited about those it's some
great tech and
i think in some ways some of the most
practical and clinically applicable
it's it's got a straightforwardness to
it zen
is cool mysterious and poetic and kind
of like you know non-mappy which is
super groovy in its way and quite
profound and then the tibetans are like
super flowery and ultra complicated and
lots of robes and hats and colors and
deities and all that
but the theravada you know even though
it actually is super complicated it's
in its forms and actually i was just
reading a really cool book called
esoteric teravata
that actually talks about how
complicated and rich the theravada
sort of used to be and still is in a few
places but it was actually
very vajrianaish in terms of these
elaborate systems of
symbols and poly words throughout the
body and medicine and channels and
implications and characteristics and it
actually used to be
much stranger and actually still and a
lot and more interesting and rich and
diverse
and it's still in actually some places
if you go
and um see how this is actually
operationalized in places like thailand
and particularly as you sort of
get up in like the northwest and some of
the more remote areas like it's very
mix of shamanic and deities and magic
and
and all kinds of stuff mixed in it's
it's not straightforward and you can
still see
vajrayana and mahayana influences even
in it even though they tried to kind of
like get rid of all of that in
the 1800s and thailand and stuff and
some other kind of reform movements
it's still there so actually buddhism is
way more complicated than most people
think it is it's this rich melting pot
of diversity and
even within single traditions amazing
complexity i mean like
just if you said zen or pure land or
whatever these are huge complicated
traditions with many different schools
teachings texts emphasis you know tips
and tricks and
so anyway so it's it's an amazingly rich
thing and then like how that relates to
vedanto or shaiva tantra
or you know what is shingon where does
that fall in it's kind of you know and
how did taoism and
the bone tradition were bone how did
these
get blended into all of that mix this is
it's much more organic than people
generally take it for
so which is exciting right anyway
okay so there's a view of this where
carl jaspers calls this the axial age
and there's this
explosion of spiritual awakening
um and the
way that buddhism in a sense can be
visualized this is like fractaled out
similar to what you see like with
um hinduism also very fractaled out
um and now like you also indicated
what's the relationship between things
like these mystic schools like zogchen
and zen uh with advaita vedanta
and with uh gnosticism or sufi
metaphysics
then there's all of these like mystic
like union direct
union with god um and
uh so so that's that's a core i would
say that that was the core thing
that i was pointed to in the last couple
of years of studying
which led me to recognize myself as it
and us all as it undergoing an
exploration of
of infinite potential and so then
that's probably the core thing to
remember as you look at all these little
fractals of the spiritual traditions
since that
um axial age explosion is looking for
the mystic schools looking for the ones
that
talk about the direct experiential path
to unite with the kingdom of god inside
of you
and how to do that um that process so i
like that
point and then i like i like the
practicality of
theravada specifically i think it's very
practical
um vajrayana also has lots of
practicality to it
um as do many of the schools but
specifically with
i'd like for you to walk us through this
so people can get this because
we love you and the reason why the
reason why we're
doing this in many ways is to help
distill something relatable for you to
help you with
your everyday life so let's go through
this would you say that the first
principle is becoming
aware of breath and therefore
by becoming aware of breath what we do
is become
regain sovereignty we regain will
from what was more scripted subconscious
like
behavior well there's tons of places to
start i mean breath is a great object in
a great beginning and it's used in a lot
of traditions for
a reason but there's so many other
possible starting points i mean you know
tm
starts with a mantra and some people
start with visualizations
or actually i've used i like candle
flames these days and
light casinos which are old actually
it's almost certainly pre-buddhist tech
so that almost certainly comes out of
whatever was there before buddhism
which would be some old upanishads and
they you know
etcetera influenced uh technologies but
um
yeah and some people start with prayer
and some people just tune in naturally
they're not using any object at all and
they just
enjoy the the inner journey of seeing
what is there when they just look
without filters
and then of course zogchen and mahamudra
would just start with sort of
well actually those are really
complicated traditions i should be
careful here but
the pop versions of zogchen and
mahamudra should would start with just
kind of being
in the space as object and result and
then you get the you know the non-dual
pointing traditions that just say this
is it
no and they're right you know but there
is more to it but
still they're right and so if you were
talking like you know adi ashanti
you know i shouldn't speak for him but
it's going to be just like
what is the thing that makes you think
this isn't it in general like
without a real necessary focus i mean
you know he's more you know
i shouldn't speak for these people but
you get the idea and so there are
actually
lots of ways not only there are lots of
paths
up the mountain as it were but there's a
lot of places to start on each of these
paths
and even within the theravada you know
some might start noting the breath and
is the breath here or is the breath
there and some might start with walking
and some
you know and then zazen would just be
just sitting
kind of and practice enlightenment which
is also kind of an immediate pointy
tradition and
and others are like very inquiry based
like who am i
what is this you know they're using a
question to focus you back on what is
observation or what is awareness or
consciousness
and i actually think that any of those
and more could be interesting places to
start
the thing that got me into this was
visualizing large spheres
that i would practice flying between
that was the first thing that really
made my consciousness explode and start
having
weird things when i was a teenager and
that was just a home brewed
weird visualization to have better
flying dreams you know and like
so like and i know other people who
without anything to start having
insights and then you get the reports of
the spontaneous realizers
who just woke up and they weren't doing
anything they were some of them just
kids right like
punjaji the buddha of luck now
apparently he was just seven and
kind of something changed and then like
he thought that was just normal and
then when he got older he realized no
wait a second most people don't perceive
the way i
the world the way i do oh wait this is
oh wait maybe this is awakening
yeah and you know seems to have been so
you know there's lots of places to begin
anyway sorry for
getting brought up that was really great
because to give us that broad
buffet of entry points also enables
people to realize the
straight-up diversity of entry points
which is huge but
what is most practical for
unfreezing will and regaining
sovereignty
it seems to become aware of this sort of
bell curve of arising and passing if you
sort of see yourself as the sky
the very simple child-like analogies is
like
awareness is the sky and then the
thought the thought cloud appears
and then it disappears but you have to
become
aware of it appearing and disappearing
rather than biting and fixating and
grasping and craving and averting
and that that seems to be the most would
you say that that's the most sort of
simple like cloud versus sky
juxtaposition and and working on the
breath work to help you with that
yeah so each of those metaphors every
time you introduce a metaphor or concept
or a frame
you do some good things and you do some
not so good things so for example
um i would totally agree that the
ability to see thoughts come and go as
objects is like one of the most critical
things and the tradition of mindfulness
for example
which you know is a very simple
technique
takes that and uses it for all its worth
as do a lot of the direct pointing or
some of the inquiry things or even koans
just when you see the thoughts of the
koan as object
that obviously in its way is profound
and um so yes in some ways that is one
of the most critical things and then if
you can actually
deepen that a little bit and notice all
the intentions that make up thoughts
like the sort of
the the the thing okay i'm gonna move my
hand i moved my hand and then the
recognition i did
move my hand and all that monitoring
process along the way that back and
forth iterative
really fast thing those are also kind of
in the categories of thought
to most reasonable you know by most
reasonable ways of thinking about it
though there are others
and so like each of those super quick
little thoughts like
those can you know the things the mental
impressions that think they know
something
well they're actually just little mental
impressions here that don't look really
anything like the things they thought
they knew
and the intentions to create things just
arose naturally
so if you actually take that basic
concept of seeing thought as thought and
they come and go far enough
it could totally deconstruct the sense
of time of doer
of knower of beer of continuous entity
um but then when you put it against the
frame of a stable space
in through which things come and go you
create a bit of a problem and it's a
problem that
early on and in the intermediate stages
is actually a benefit
because it points to something really
skillful about an open vastness of
experience
that is much more
able to deal with little petty stuff in
a way that's not all contracted into it
and doesn't activate the default mode
network so that's super cool right
but you create a problem later on down
the road for those of us who also would
say that space
is transient that awareness is transient
so
what you get as a side effect of then a
lot of people get very good at
solidifying a sense of a stable space as
a watching consciousness
that then has no changing elements to it
which those of us who are hardcore
terravottans would they say
yeah but you could see that come and go
too and when you do it'll do something
better
so that's where suddenly i've pissed off
some vedantists and people who think
there's a stable luminous all ground
my apologies but just realize there's
debates in this tradition and you know
do your own experiment and see which
works for you um
and at various times like that kind of
open awareness concept can be incredibly
skillful
so even sometimes it's worth dealing
with the later side effects or golden
chains that you might create
when you introduce that um still can be
quite a good idea
to get people through some of the
rougher stages and help them get some
space around their challenges and
traumas and
and neuroses and all that so so
definitely i would agree that's
that's a really key point yes
cool so almost as though
what we feel for the mainstream
is like where for example i was five
years ago and where
typically you people like you were
decades ago were
like you know how do i suffer less
uh is that typically a question like how
do i experience more happiness
and joy and peace and so the
the answer that we're providing is
becoming
aware of the simple child-like analogies
like we're using where the thoughts are
objectified as clouds that arise and
pass
in the sky of awareness but not to get
um fixated on that analogy
because what ends up happening is you
unpack more and more
deeply um what the natural state
is of existence of reality
and so i love that i feel like that's a
key insight is to is to recognize that
you're creating
a a ground that you want to actually
not be fixated on because then it allows
you to move past that ground
as you unlock deeper and deeper insights
that free you
more and more okay so that's beautiful
okay and then
now as you become
more sovereign and you feel like okay
i used to this is an analogy that i feel
like is so common
for for people um sometimes
before you know it this is probably one
of the most common ones is
before you know it you have you're
eating a
a pint of ice cream before you know it
right
and then what typically happens is um
maybe you used to just go through the
whole thing
and now what you started to notice is
you're halfway through it
and now you're like i shouldn't be
eating this just because i'm sad and
like i want to eat this right now um and
so you
now you're halfway through so now you've
got there are worse coping mechanisms by
the way like if that keeps you from
doing something worse maybe the ice
cream is better
unless you're a bad diabetic in which
case be careful kids but you know like
they're okay but yeah i hear you sure
cool so disclaimer yes um
and so we have this this example where
you feel like you're actually regaining
sovereignty you're regaining will
because
now you're only halfway through and
you've realized that
and now next time what is
how what's what's arising is you're
you realize that the thought cloud of i
should eat ice cream right now
arises and you see it you have like this
awareness
of seeing it and then you're you're not
biting and you're not fixating on it and
then it dissolves and before you know it
you're like i don't i didn't really
actually want
to eat ice cream i just watched that
appear and disappear
and so okay so now you can see these
like practical examples are for
for guys another common one is that they
feel
like this this primal erection
and they feel like this primal desire to
want to go and watch porn and masturbate
and if you sort of just relax yourself
and you can sort of watch your
your hard erection dissolve you can
watch that
urge to want to go in and masturbate
dissolve
and another one for guys that's pretty
common is that they feel like
that they want to go and do stuff like
men are all about doing and acting
and what happens if you just sit on the
couch and do
nothing what happens is that you
become more and more like relaxed into
us
again a very spacious sense of in a
sense emptiness
like you're watching things arise and
pass without acting and you're just
noticing the nature of your mind
itself and so you're regaining will
you're regaining sovereignty by doing
these styles of acts
that you're typically programmed to not
do and in doing so you're gaining well
you're gaining sovereignty
and then you're you feel like you're
becoming more
awakened and you're less conditioned so
this seems to be like the most
simple mainstream visuals and relatable
examples
do you feel like that's resonance stuff
like that absolutely and there's a great
book uh
on this by the way called the craving
mind by judd brewer which i just
yeah it's it talks about a lot of this
kind of tech and he's done a lot of work
with addiction and cravings and stuff so
very skillful um cool work and
you know backed by a bunch of
neuroscience as well so that's neat
and um and so definitely in terms of a
practical
practical example and sovereignty is a
very interesting word
because the the relationship between the
sense of control
and the sense of will and ego and the
sense of natural unfolding
is this very strange thing in the world
of
meditation and spirituality right with
all these i mean
practically people not only notice wow i
seem to have no control of my thoughts
or my body
but they also then will notice weight as
i meditate more i do seem to have
more control of my thoughts in my body
but wait i'm noticing more
and more the degree to which i both do
not and do
have control of my thoughts and my body
and so it's this very weird thing and
then like is spiritual
awakening to gain complete control of
everything is a truly separate entity
that somehow
seems to stand outside of all other
biological conditioning and causality
as a true sovereign thing that somehow
is a true self
separate from all conditioning or is it
to recognize like no will but thine and
to totally dissolve into the natural
unfolding of
the universe or whatever and the
unfolding of the dow or whatever so
there's
so one just has to um realize that along
the way
one is likely to run into experientially
very practically
both skillful applications of the sense
of will and control
and the sense of sovereignty as you put
it but also
skillful appreciations of the natural
unfolding of things
and so that's one of those fascinating
dances that there's endless schools of
thought on and advice on but i just want
to kind of
point that out right so and both have
their points
um actually the way that theravada kind
of breaks this down
which i like a lot is basically the
first
so theravada like going back to old
theravada basic tech race
three trainings right and actually a lot
of the schools of buddhism would kind of
appreciate the three trainings
or the eight spoke wheel the dharma or
the eightfold noble path which is broken
down into three basic
and the first one is sila or sheila
which is going to be
you know could translate it as ethics or
morality or
good behavior or something which is
basically skillful use of body speech
and mind
write you know right thought right
livelihood right action write speech
those kinds of things
and then um so and then thinking about
like how and that basically assumes that
we have control
of our bodies that we can follow
precepts that we can direct our minds to
things that we can
say better things or send love
intentionally to other people or
or intentionally try to be more
economists in situations it very much
has the assumption
explicitly baked into it as a
fundamental thing of
will of sovereignty of doer that can do
better that through paying attention
can learn to do better in the face of
this human mammalian experience
and then there's the second training
samadhi or
you know concentration um which often is
called shamatha practices or something
which should be the fact that with will
we can suppress the hindrances of
doubt and fear and anger and desire
whatever we can kind of push those away
and instead calm down
stay with our meditation objects do
something really
deeply skillful with our minds that gets
into you know blissful or peaceful or
exotic states of consciousness
right or do magic or whatever and but
that's still
very much expressly kind of involving a
sense of will but now it's starting to
get a little weird
because the higher genres actually talk
about with the dropping of
applied and sustained effort and energy
or attention you can get into the higher
state so suddenly it's got this weird
thing where you start off
with the assumption of will and control
and technique and
and suppression of bad things and
cultivation of good things but then to
get farther you have to be able to kind
of roll with the flow and so suddenly
it's getting a little strange
and then you get explicitly to the last
training of insider wisdom
which starts straight out of the gate
with three characteristics that
none of this is you that it's all just
the natural unfolding of causes and
conditions that it all changes and
there's no
separate observer doer control or beer
but for most people to do that they kind
of need to start with some
will-based assumptions right and then
even most of the
like you know the catholic mystical
tradition explicitly says
you know you try to purify yourself
through effort and eventually god or
jesus just takes over
you know and divine spirit just comes
through you and you find similar things
in basically all the traditions because
it's just part of the
the weirdness of the spiritual path
right are you doing this is it doing
this and
where do those lines begin and end right
so
um yeah this is the deep questions that
are fun to explore in one's own
heart mind body system and space in
general
yeah i'm so happy that you took us there
across the mystic traditions there seems
to be this similarity
where there is a
realization that the individuated
firework
has where it goes okay
i initially was coming from
a place of what felt to be more
scripted behavior and patterns that
weren't
my own that i didn't pick up that were
more around conditioning
and then now is that still the divine
yes it is
um but then you realize that okay well
where
can i actually unfreeze some of that
will and choice and and pattern and
behavior
where i can actually
have more sovereignty to not
in not grasp and not fixate and not be
scripted
and instead focus like turn inward
and recognize well this is the kingdom
of god this
is the tao this is it and so now
in a sense that i am that
that becomes clearly me i unite with
that force that i was the whole time
but that was apparently veiled through
what was maybe more limbic or more
primal or more scripted
styles of behavior and clouded
choice and so i love that sort of focus
on
first is unfreezing will and choice
and then second is the relinquishing
of said frozen uh the said willer choice
that was regained
into that uh metaversal dao um as you
could say yeah
that's cool great distinction
absolutely
and and i think that's really important
for mainstream to recognize is that
you're both going to go through a
process of
knowing yourself and your unique frames
of life
and then unfreezing more and more will
and choice
into both like self-actualization and
self-realization
um both and then you're gonna go through
a process of
surrendering that to the force that gave
rise to you
because you recognize that that's the
same force that gave rise to everything
and that it's all one intelligence
undergoing this dance
with itself well it's interesting how
you use ontologies right because you
you're it's it's fascinating to see the
degree to which you're
kind of a diet in the world perennialist
in terms of your ontologies
and if i can just talk about ontologies
real quick because i think it's an
important point
like i've probably said this before on
some podcast but if if
as a scientist or as a person who
appreciates bayesian thinking where you
start with some hypotheses
you put initial you know guesses that
these things are true and then you do
some
experiment that hopefully moves you in
some direction
to get a better sense of which of those
might be true
like if someone said to me like here's
four hypotheses
one is that this is all a matrix this is
all in a computer simulation
speaking of simulations we had to bring
that in somehow right
or two this is all the dream of the
great god
vishnu or brahma or inder pick your
favorite god
you think is dreaming this or three this
is
all solipsism that my mind or your mind
or somebody's mind is actually creating
all of this and there's just
one of our brains that just happens to
be doing this regardless of whether or
not we recognize that
or four that that consciousness is some
like
emergent property of insate you know
sorry in sensate particles and forces
hand wavy hand wave a handwave the
emergence
that then leads to consciousness right
and so and someone said to me
okay you know pick one of those
or like you know assign pretest
probabilities to each of those well i
have no idea how to do that
right which is more likely i don't know
i'm not sure i could tell for certain
and then someone said okay do an
experiment that would then
you know that hopefully good experiments
will you know flush out bad priors and
then
lead towards truth well i don't even
know what experiment to do
and in my own practice i have actually
had
you know experiences that at least in
the moment
were unbelievably compelling in terms of
i am in complete control or
this is totally just the dance of the
unfolding universe or
you know like everything is totally just
mind made and is all utterly up for
grabs and seemingly as
constructed and arbitrary as anything or
like
no truth is truly this seems to be the
unfolding of a divine
god-like unbelievable intelligence that
can know
create do all this and all power
knowledge and wisdom and everything and
unfolding and creation and destruction
are that not only come from that but are
that and i've
you know and all of this is dissolving
emptiness and none of it truly exists
and like i've had past life experience
with where i was some massive being
that could see parallel universes and
see all these possible options of
pathways to go down
and could then throw its life
consciousness somehow down one of those
pathways that it considered optimal
after eons of exploration
so it was a totally multi-universe and
that seemed incredibly compelling and
psychologically transformative somehow
and yet i've also had experiences that
seem to say
even this single universe cannot
possibly hold up to scrutiny there can't
even be anything other than this
dissolving moment how is there
there's no possible true past or true
future and each of these experiences
i've had
as compellingly as i could possibly
imagine such that in the moment
they seemed like of course that is true
to the very barrel of
my bones or whatever and and and yet
like
then i'm left with just pragmatism at
this point
like what really helps lead to good
outcomes and what seems to make a
difference in terms of reducing
suffering
um i actually find that as interesting
actually
way more interesting now than any of the
ontological questions
except as various adopted ontological
frames
might help you as a person given your
conditioning or tradition or culture
or background or aesthetics or whatever
have better outcomes right so i actually
think there are reasons for practically
adopting certain ontologies
because i've seen people who just
adopted one and fixed on it and it was
unbelievably good for them no question
and i've also seen people who thrive
in the metaverse of meta ontologies and
you know
trying them on and off like you know
people in a dressing room at a clothing
store
and just having fun with that like
playing costume and dress-up just
because it's a good time and we can
you know and so and so i can appreciate
both of those perspectives but just
because
you dance around the meta ontology verse
you know very comfortably which is great
you know but just recognizing that
there are other people that like no
single ontologies and single traditions
like do work well for them you know and
that and this
notion of doubt or confusion that comes
from that is just really confusing to
them
and so just sort of throw that out there
um
this really also plays into the
perfection
as it is and so therefore there's not a
there's not a there's not a tendency or
a desire to go and change
um said a configuration of what reality
is
right now um given any of these
individuated fireworks
and so this content is a mechanism that
we generate together
out of play and then and then out of
somebody else's interest in uh the
unfolding of what
could be a higher possibility for
themselves potentially extracts
something useful from it
and whatnot and so that's a critical
lens to see things as
is the the lens of both the that all is
perfect
and the lens of the individuation that
is using their
unique ontology cool and then the
individuation that's able to
thrive by switching between ontologies
these different lenses of perception
also cool and to like be able to see
that rather than
that oh you have to switch to seeing
all the different lenses at any time so
that's really um
critical because actually over time what
will happen is that
um potentially even across lifetimes is
that the
the mind will over time uh
d contract itself from the single
viewpoint um towards the all
the viewpoint of the all um and that
that's potentially what
is uh unfolding is that um the more that
you
see the all um the more that you have a
holistic take on the unfolding
this is actually a good question to ask
next is that
would it would it be fair to say that
there is then a shift that goes from
this egoic contracted separate energy
to what feels like a more free formless
aware conscious energy
and then from there there seems to be
the
the two-sided coin of what is a
an absolute empty nothingness and an
absolute
infinite creation and do you
how do you feel about that um that style
of kind of
like notches back yeah that's a pretty
good map actually
and um yeah and recognize that just maps
like that are going to have a cyclical
component
right where most people will go through
a lot of different like little cycles
like your shirts big cycles and super
big cycles of kind of
relating to each of those kind of modes
of appreciating things
and i think yeah i think that circular
nature is critical to point out because
i think a lot of people
like after some big unit of experience
where
when like you know what i would call
like a rising and passing away stuff or
maybe equanimity
they then get into some experience where
everything is kind of dissolving or
disappearing or kind of not there
they feel one with everything and then
that everything isn't stable and then
wait what does that mean and then like
this isn't stable and like
and then all of a sudden it's all open
and flowy and luminous and clear and
divine again and then it's all
contracting again like
just recognize that is also the nature
of this path kind of like weather
and i think most i think where a lot of
people go wrong particularly when
they've run into some beginner
meditation instructions or techniques or
theories
is that they kind of assume some linear
progression of like more control or more
concentration or more focus or more
silence or more whatever
and then reality doesn't do that and
then their model wasn't quite
adaptable enough or their technique
range or
sense of tools and tricks in their tool
bag couldn't kind of adapt to the funny
things that the universe then does which
might be
very contracted or expansive or
integrative
or fragmented or dissolving or
coalescing
or whatever because those are all things
that experience does and can do them
more and more and more dramatically as
we get deeper into this or people take
psychedelics or
have other powerful experiences through
whatever modalities
and just i think it's important to keep
in mind that it's good to
not be too fixed on one's models even
one's models of progress like
i will go through you know sovereignty
and then i'll go through detachment of
energy and then i will go through
nothingness allness or something
right but just like a lot of those kinds
of themes may roll through at various
points
and then and because i think people can
get sort of confused by the sense of
order or hierarchy
or whatever and most people have their
preference for one
some people super like unitive states
some people super like dissolve states
like the more aversive types
some people super like rapturous states
the more you know
uh uh so and some people super like
yeah um really like expansive calm
states right and so they'll kind of
usually kind of gravitate towards a
tradition that kind of
um uh gives one primacy
right but then reality might do all
these other things that aren't the
things they like the most or their
tradition emphasizes the most
and then i think that can be confusing
to people so just recognize if you're
we're all in this journey to some degree
right just you know
be able to have a tradition that can
kind of roll with the range
and be wary of pure perfectly linear
progression models that are all going to
work out like everybody thinks they will
so if that's helpful not that all those
experiences might not unfold in that
progression they totally might
that's a really helpful insight because
you're gonna end up cycling yourself
into more advanced ways of perception
and that that in a sense is kind of what
the nature of reality feels like is this
uh is this augmentation
of perception over time basically um
and that the
now is that is that not to say that out
of infinite exploration that there may
be actually
what appear to be um a period of
um perception increasing in some way but
then also turning into
a serial killer which is actually
deemed as not an augmentation in in
perception so
it's not always um necessarily portrayed
that way but as
it as a general universal cosmological
phenomenon not necessarily at an
individuated level
but at a universal cosmological
phenomenon it does appear
like awareness becomes
um more uh
aware of what
its point is of what the explorative
point is of what's of what's happening
and then
it does things like well you can yeah
please please hit that and then i'll go
into some
of the other questions it sounded like
you had an insight there
yeah so i mean in terms of cosmic when
you say cosmic do you mean in time
scale or in the size of space what do
you just so i
react properly to the word like you mean
over like eons or
over what does that word mean to you so
i understand how you operationalize it
and can address it
good question if we were to play with
what
appear to be one of the most simple
child-like
ways of visualizing the nature of
reality it seems like
it's a uh a single
infinite unified intelligence that
in a sense refracts itself
into differentiation based on
um these the generation of these you you
of these universes so generating these
universes
um in its process of a play to
differentiate itself as these entities
in a sort of play in a sort of
exploration of that infinite possibility
and that in this refraction there's like
an ascension
that looks like a metamorphosis it looks
like the caterpillar turns into a
butterfly
and so um that's what i would say is
uh the that appears to be the nature
um do you want to talk about some of the
experiences you had that
led you to those to those insights
and how those happen do you ever talk
about yourself on this
podcast oh you're so sweet
um i actually have a
um along with these interviews i do
these like direct
disseminations of what feels like as the
most like
yeah that i apologize if i've not seen
all those
no no no not at all and actually i would
i would say that this is becoming more
and more important
because um we just had like kurt geiman
go on the show who
also does these incredible interviews on
theories of everything
but now here's the thing is that are
these interviewers and
are these um polymaths are these people
that are scraping from science
and spirituality i would say it's also
beautiful for them to undergo a process
of can i distill
what i've learned into these little 15
minute videos and stuff like that
and so i would say that that's a really
important process for people
to do and so um so just to hit the ball
back for
for a moment there is how
does the what i shared with you those
two analogies
how does the that that that infinite
intelligence
refracting itself into the
differentiation that then looks like a
metamorphosis
in its ascension how does that um
resonate
with you i have definitely had some
experiences that would
lend a lot of resonance with that kind
of a view
um in various contexts and i
very much appreciate that kind of vibe
and for people who have had those kinds
of experiences however you got to them
um i think they'll also be resonating
with this and going well yeah
of course but i could also
see how there might be totally different
interpretations of experiences
that could lead to those senses of
a cosmically waking up evolving
metamorphosis
metamorphing and um embryo
embryologically developing or
maturing universal intelligence
and so um uh
whereas one could see all of those as
just
i mean because you could get super
terravodney about this and go
well actually those meanings are also
just a rising little fragments of stuff
that happen as this natural unfolding of
say
the four you know foundations of
mindfulness or the aggregates or
the sixth sense stores you know or the
one
cent store where really there's just the
primacy of immediate experience and one
can find
if one truly just looks at this is raw
sense data as raw as we have access to
obviously it's pretty
pre-processed it seems before we get it
but that there is literally
nothing but this unfolding immediate
experiential moment
and any thoughts of a past or a future
or a continuous evolving consciousness
or an intelligence are just these little
meaning flakes
that kind of fragment and just occur in
this immediate moment
and so even one can find no continuous
stable evolving intelligence that could
become
anything that could be anything instead
we just find this immediate
scintillating
uh luminous empty transient present
dance
right and so i could totally then throw
that back on you and
you know and but i i can appreciate the
beauty
of both and so i think i think those
kinds of
senses of developmental consciousness
that have a sense of a past and a future
to them
and take those at face value focusing on
the meaning rather than the immediate
essence of the experience
that has mythic resonance that is super
powerful and beautiful
and plays to parts of myself that have
experienced things that made me
think stuff exactly like that and go
well yeah and then there's another part
of me that goes
but yet to try to actually find any true
past or true future or even stable
present
is impossible and so how could there be
anything that's continuous and actually
evolving
rather than just this and i have deep
mythic resonance with both of those and
i've gotten a lot of practical utility
about exploring both
so if just to richen it up a little bit
what are your thoughts
oh gosh that was so good so it's almost
like mythic resonance plus
simply this both delightful and i think
are really important and
different sides of ourselves thrive on
both of those kinds of ways of knowing
and being
so if you look at the work of rob berbea
or plenty of people who have drawn on
his stuff um or uh
yeah you could you can see um a lot of
people who are talking
a number of podcasts i've been on
talking about very validly
that the mythic archetypal um sides of
ourselves that respond to those kinds of
big grand stories and explanations
regardless of anything about their
immediate dissolving emptiness or
whatever
like it's important to to deeply explore
those sides of ourselves because that
actually drives a tremendous amount of
human behavior as well as wars over
religion
as well as incredibly visionary you know
next steps in technology and
you know if if you look at people who
have these incredibly visionary mythic
experiences like renee descartes or
clearly newton or einstein
and suddenly you know our countless
artists and poets and authors and
mathematicians and you know like some
they had
some vision of something like that and
then something super cool and awesome
came out of it
yes right and and on the other hand so
it would be it would be
cruel and and really missing half of the
party
to just simply this that you know right
it would seem and yet from another
freeing point of view to be able to
simultaneously have the option to simply
this those
incredibly mythic story things is also
really valuable
so i think it's good to have the
optionality and the fluency to be
comfortable in both realms as
comfortable as any of us can be in any
of this
it kind of also reminds me of map and
no map absolutely that's the same
problem yep yeah
yeah i love that that's great and so and
that's good
that was brilliant yeah nice that was so
good and then it also
and then it also brings for this true
simultaneity
so can you truly simultaneously
be able to have both a mythic resonance
lens
and a simply this lens lens or a map
lens and a no-map lens
simultaneously yeah and obviously that's
what reality is doing anyway
but it is definitely possible to become
more and more
let's just say awake to that yeah no
question
perfect um and eventually like they
seem the same the the thoughts of myth
at once can convey their full
full range human emotional deep
you know psychological archetypal
universal and
you know consciousness or whatever
resonance while being experienced
as just dissolving empty things now
that's actually what you know a lot of
the maps would then point to that as
being essentially the grand cosmic
existential experiential and spiritual
punchline
you know or one of them anyway so yes
this definitely feels like one of the
core cosmic punch lines is that
there's both this there's this there's
this
inward attractor which is like map
me it's like me understand me
that kind of a thing and then there's
another attractor
which is basically like i am eternally
infinitely creating and um you're never
going to be able to bound me ever
so why create maps and i love
yes and i love those two attractors
being able to hold them simultaneously
it almost
it almost seems to be the point is can
you awaken it enough
in the creation to where you can find
the other expressions of yourself
that can play tennis um
where you can get as close as possible
to understanding the one intelligence
and what it's doing
um and how it's playing part of the part
of the game
and to actually bring back in some of
your earlier stuff you are very validly
talking about
about learning to see thoughts as
thoughts like when people get run into
the maps
the first thing they usually do is
totally fix on them and forget to see
the thoughts of maps as thoughts
right and so that can be kind of there's
a learning curve and a maturation curve
in that instead they totally obsess
about become desirous of
think are true things are the true a
true meditator that will be there in a
true future that will have a true
attainment that is a stable
actually thing they could hold or that
somebody could hold it or whatever
right and they they forget the basic
things they learned along the way and so
there is a maturation about all maps
but there is a way eventually to learn
to have maps just be more colors
textures meanings implications of of
you know development that just arise in
this moment
and do sort of self-liberate as the
tibetans might
you know call it or the the co-rising of
wisdom
and emptiness and compassion just uh
sort of happening you the the built-in
nature of map thoughts
being the answer to the maps they're
seemingly a map to
um uh they you know that
that process is definitely how people
when they run into maps then get better
yeah and get over it uh because this is
of course still
it um and then it's just a question of
that doesn't mean maps can be incredibly
useful i'm
actually a super map geek i probably
have literally 100 books or more on the
shelf behind me
that are variants of maps of spiritual
progress
and attainments and awakenings and goals
and techniques to do that and all that
you know
countless um yeah so for example this
one if you've seen this one right this
is a map to this moment
so people use these maps to stumble
towards this moment as fast as they can
possibly go
but still something in that stumbling
based on map fixation of a true future
can be incredibly useful
yeah and this is my like map geekery and
it actually gets way worse than this
um this is this doesn't involve all the
sub genres and subjiana's and
sub variants and and all of that is
right so this is the light end of my map
weirdness um but still hopefully it's
hopefully
something that people can use i mean i
found
maps incredibly valuable right they were
very validating
they helped me avoid common pitfalls
they helped normalize experience
they helped me prepare for what i might
be going into such that i wasn't
surprised by it or shocked by it they
helped me with issues of timing and
technique
and and also just gave me tremendous
faith
that wow if this part of the map was
true maybe the rest of it's true that
kind of stuff
which is a mixed blessing because mixed
quality of maps i was working with
um but yeah but you know that said some
people are also
really like and here's the other problem
there's
there's the problem of of people who
love the maps
and do well with the maps cool they see
a map and they can follow it well they
can hold it with appropriate
maturity they can use it to investigate
their immediate experience
they don't become all future fixated on
it and then there are people
who don't love the maps and do great not
loving the maps
you just say intuitively feel into the
the cosmic oneness or whatever
or you know or just be with this and
they just do that and they don't need a
map they're just here
and then you find the other two
quadrants of the mix and that's where
the problems come in
are the people who really love the maps
and kind of suck at using them and they
just run them ragged and they get all
obsessive and strivy and they're just
no you're freaking horrible about this
and like maybe
maps were not for you or not without a
lot of training and guidance of how to
use them and
not them be a disaster and then you also
get the people
who freaking hate the maps and god they
kind of really needed them actually like
no you needed a map and with maps maybe
you would have done a lot better
so you get all four quadrants of that
and then mixes and then actually people
will move around between these
during their lifetimes which could be
really confusing they can do great
without the maps for a while and then
they run into something that
nah a map helps them with that and other
people like they do great with the maps
for you know
for a while and then um you know uh
so did i say that the other way i may
have mixed this up anyway whatever they
do great with the maps
and then like they start really running
into a problem of something they fix on
something they hinge on something they
solidify and they just cannot friggin
get over it and they just need to let
them go you know and just be
just be with what's going on and and
learn to surf rather than like
try to do the mathematics of surfing
while on the surfboard
yeah perfect perfect way to put it
it'd be like if you're if you're making
your scrambled eggs and you're trying to
do the math of how much salt and pepper
to put into them
whatever yeah it's yeah like art it's
such slow exactly yeah
yeah so yeah yeah that's my summary of
map stuff
yeah that's great that's great yeah
ain't nobody doing math and physics
while surfing
it's just not happening um yeah that is
a great one
oh man because i can't even begin
telling you how
important the maps were for me awakening
well actually do tell me about that i'd
love to hear it because it's you know
it's validating of some of my own weird
geekery
yes yes even yours have been so
profoundly influential
and i i can't there's been like a dozen
that have been just so
just mission critical i have a maps
folder
in mind you talk about those because
i've been talking a lot do you mind
because i would actually love to hear
your take on this
because because i've i know my own takes
on maps and people might and probably a
lot of people may
you know know some of my takes and your
audience may know all of your takes
but like i'd just love to hear some of
them personally
okay so i'll pull this one up and what
you found useful and not useful and when
and like how you use when to pick each
one because that's also interesting
right
that meta tech yeah oh that's cool yep
yep
um i feel like so much of that is
intuitive almost like
it um like the salting of the eggs type
thing
um and when it almost it comes
itself but then you have to graduate
from
the map uh to use it in ways that
both serve you continuously and also
serve you with by not using it and then
also serve
other people by introducing them to it
okay
so this would be just a very brief
visual
nice yeah i have a little um threesome
that i
this i call this one the quad because i
just threw the infinity expressing
itself in the top left corner but
it's really just three maps um you have
the classic
levels of consciousness by david hawkins
on the bottom left
you have the classic spiral dynamics um
that's claire graves and don beck chris
cowan
also ken wilbur on bottom right corner
and then you have the top right
is the raw the channeled material the
law of one the seven
density model of consciousness and so
these three i would say in the last year
have been the most
um profound or influential um for me
and it sounds like you're familiar with
all three of them right off the bat
yeah to various degrees actually my
friend gareth was just telling me
about the raw law of one stuff and a
little bit so that's the one i actually
know the least well but looking at it
it's actually very
familiar tech right that's that's pretty
similar to a bunch of other
maps in that same kind of neck of the
woods you know
um that reminds me it goes all the way
to blavatsky and the
theosophists and and those kinds of
people and then moving forward so it's
it's yeah
through my new agey background and uh my
um yeah kind of blavatsky days like i
have a sense of some of that stuff
because it's it's in the same vein
cool nice but with its own yeah i see
some distinctions there that's really
interesting
and then how do you know to move versus
one to the other if they become all
natural to you
let me let me uh that's a great question
i feel like
um um let me let me
pull up one can you plant flag with that
question how to move
actually i can transition so one of one
of the things that
what what i would do is i would take the
maps
and i would try and distill their
essence
into another map that i would generate
as an as an artist and that would be
sort of
like can we move on to a higher level
okay so this would be
let me i'll pull this one up so this is
one that i
um uh wait a second
full screen that and then
okay so yeah so this one came through
about i think in march um and so this
begins to play on what we were talking
about which
is um can you go from
the uh can we use these analogies where
you have this
absolute source dow god brahman void
infinity
um refracting itself through this uh
awareness consciousness witness observer
seer and
and in exploring infinite creation
planets earth civilizations people names
forms ten thousand things
and can you make the shift from the
transient from the i am the person
identity as the ultimate litmus test
shifting to this
i am the witness or i am awareness or i
am consciousness
all the way to i am this indescribable
downness
uh creator emptiness infinitude um
and undergoing yeah that anyway so then
this
was another sort of map that was
generated yeah
the dark side of the moon map anyway yes
yes
and so there's that and then i would say
um
another somewhat um another quite i
think
good and important one um to visualize
at least just for a second would be um
this one has also been profoundly
influential and this one is bentino
masaro's
map and so he has this uh
similar style of i am this person
um you know on the planet on the right
uh more of a contracted
focused on subject object duality
and then this shift into the the i
am-ness
the presence energy um just the shift
into becoming aware that i
am this formless indescribable power to
know um
and then the shift even further into
this
eye solely eye just indescribable i-ness
um awareness and then shifting into this
beyond eye
indescribable infinitude beyond this and
so this has been another
um interesting map and so i would say
this one
and that is what fun yeah
the maps i feel like are a mission
critical
for the process but then like you
described also to not be
at any point attached but to also be
interested in
the like how does infinity try to map
itself
and then how does it try to awaken
itself
in the expression by creating these maps
that then facilitate its awakening
but also that don't get attached to
those maps
and so thanks for asking about that i
feel like that's
the map part is really important you
know where i feel like would be a good
transition for us now is into um
how do we um
take what we talked about the beginning
which was this very practical style of
how do i suffer less
feel more peace and happiness by
unfreezing some of my will and
sovereignty
and then how do i undergo that process
of realizing myself as the
ultimate or the supreme but how do we
merge that
um with the mainstream
um architectural processes this would be
a good transition to the emergent
phenomenology research consortium which
the eprc and then also
e-benefactors emergence benefactors and
so
um we'll let dan explain this but just
on a high level this is what we were
talking about also earlier with
merging science and spirituality and
aiming to
unlock a lot of the planetary um
finances as well and funnel it into
these architectural advancements that
merge science and spirituality so that
as people are
awakening and realizing these higher
states of consciousness that there's
like
landing zones and there's integration
for them and there's
um even at places like the dsm-5 and
clinical research so
let's have dan unpack this i love this
nice so i'm gonna i'm gonna go
into shameless plug mode for the charity
i'm now the acting ceo and board chair
of emergence benefactors
which is trying to raise literally
hundreds of millions of dollars to do
this
kind of research so shameless plug for
the charity but this is important
so the basic problem is that
practices that can lead to what we're
going to call emergent phenomena by
which we mean magical
mystical spiritual etc phenomena pick
your favorite terms for these things
um uh we're and we we're hitting pretty
broadly of that so we mean
everything from energetics to perceptual
distortions to mood highs and lows and
relative insights and ultimate insights
and all that
dark nights and and peak experiences and
all that kind of stuff
that can happen as a result of
meditation psychedelics you know giving
birth to children walking down the
street intensive exercise
military service intensive training and
just being alive
right some people just get into this
stuff for no clearly obvious reason than
sometimes when they're weirdly young
and so and the problem is is that the
clinical mainstream as you know
because i'm a board-certified er doctor
at least was i you know i'm not
practicing anymore so i
retired a few years ago but so i went
through the whole clinical mainstream
thing
and there's literally nothing useful
except a few lines that were the the
mighty uh david lukkov uh um francis
slough and robert turner managed to get
into the dsm in 1993 there's only a few
lines
that they've ever managed to get in that
are helpful and most people don't really
know how to implement them or use them
that help people with this stuff if they
run into the mainstream
medical or mental health world because
you know if you've got energy blazing up
and down your spine and think you're now
the god queen of the universe or
whatever
like there are no boxes to put you in
that that you're gonna like
in the clinical mainstream and that's a
problem because
you know a lot of people's soteriologies
a lot of my friends
um think that it's gonna be some sort of
expanded consciousness
that's gonna save the planet we're gonna
wake up and grow up and clean up
and and you know show up and whatever to
use sort of a willberry and model of
this
stuff of what we're going to do but the
problem is
that you know i hung out a shingle like
20 something years ago instead of if
you're having weird spiritual
experiences i'll talk to you about them
for free
and then when you do that you get to
talk to thousands of people who have had
super weird experiences
and some non-trivial portion of them ran
into the health care system
which then from my point of view did
terrible things with them and i totally
understand why
because if i had nothing other than my
training as a doctor i would have done
terrible things to them
right except and the problem is that
we've never given them the boxes
that they can put these people into or
the data-driven management strategies or
diagnostic categories that hopefully
have some sort of neuroscientific
pharmacological
correlates you know if you're going to
use medications which one to use and if
you're not going to use
medications you have you know
time-tested strategies that we know help
them ground down
or or you know feel better or be less
depressed or less
hallucinatory if that's what they want
to be or whatever it is
you know and so you know and that we we
give them options that are more
accepting of the possible ontologies
that people like yourself and myself
are comfortable swirling in or the
religious traditions they're coming from
or whatever and we we um you know we we
help them to have better outcomes
because the problem is
my colleagues in you know internal you
know medicine and
pediatrics and neurology and emergency
psychiatry and emergency medicine and
and even like orthopedics and you know
some of these people have weird muscle
bizarre movements
tremors and strange kundalini stuff they
end up seeing you know
physiatrists and and body workers and
stuff they don't have enough
frameworks they don't have enough
validation they don't have enough
diagnostic codes
they don't have enough good science to
really show them what to do with these
people
and um and all of the religious
traditions actually think they're the
best and the fastest and the most
complete and the most profound and the
most
true and the most helpful and the most
developed and the most skillful
and whatever at getting people to
whatever their sorterological goals are
but i actually pro probably don't think
any of that's true and i'm currently
fascinated by what i call the mixed
martial arts model
where basically all the traditions like
karate and jujitsu and capoeira and
whatever
you know muay thai they all thought they
were the best and
none of them were mixed martial arts
pretty much definitively showed i think
by countless youtube video after
countless youtube video
that a mixed martial artist of
equivalent strength weight and training
stepping
into the ring with a a fighter of a
single style with equivalent strength
weight and training
is pretty much just going to kill them
right and so i think the experiment has
been done
and but with the peaceful arts the
peaceful meditative arts i think a
similar experiment needs to be done
where a lot of the traditions have
tremendously cool tech for handling
energetic experiences
for doing something skillful with
magical or you know entity experiences
or profound shifts in consciousness or
paradigm or existential whatever
or ontology that can happen as a result
of these transformative
practices and experiences but i don't
think any of them
like have it all as i look at all of
them because i've studied pretty widely
i see well that one does this one's
super cool and that one does this one
really well
and what i actually want to do is let's
do the science on this and actually show
without have
smashing people's faces in but instead
what leads people
who want to have very powerful
experiences and not wreck their lives
to have those for people who just want
to be able to calm down without running
into powerful experiences that wreck
their lives
to have that or if people run into these
powerful experiences or
you know that they don't relate to well
to be able to
to add value to care if they show up in
a mainstream
setting and to empower my colleagues in
medicine who
generally went into this to know good
things to be able to do useful things
for people
to be able to do that rather than right
at the moment they don't know much and
they're
sometimes kind of or very harmful um and
kind of sovereignty violating as they
take away people's rights and put them
in hospitals and stuff
i actually talked to a guy about a
little over a month ago i think at this
point
who was intentionally practicing very
powerful meditation techniques and they
got into a stage that i would call the
arising and passing away
and they knew that this was a peak
experience with lots of energy an
incredibly precise powerful mind
and they knew people were studying this
stuff and they walked into their local
hospital
this is intentional experiences they
were cultivating right and they said
hey do you have a scientist that can
study me right because i'm having this
right now
and i thought it'd be a cool research
subject and they naively thought this
was a good idea they're like oh no
like so don't do this by the way this is
not a good idea it's not safe
right right now but he was not dangerous
not a harm to sell for others he knew
what he was doing he had intentionally
cultivated these experiences
and they forced him into the hospital
forced medicated to him for a day until
he managed to talk his way out of it
and convince him he wasn't dangerous and
this is a religious problems
in canada and that because it's a
spiritual thing they couldn't hold him
against his will
but like yeah like and that's just gotta
stop like
i'm sorry like that's not cool right and
the problem is to stop it is going to
take a staggering amount of work because
for 120 years the trans-personal kids
have been knocking on the mainstream's
door unfortunately in pretty much all
the wrong ways with language that's
never going to fly i'm sorry i don't
mean to
like maybe kundalini is going to be an
icd-11 billing code i don't know but
maybe like convince me but like until
then we probably need
language that's not you know that could
scale globally and not
piss off muslims and christians and
other what people who don't
like that language because it's based on
some religious tradition or whatever
you know and so i think there is a way
that the clinical world actually what it
does do well is just like hey a
gallbladder is a gallbladder and we take
it out and i don't mean to produce
spirituality to kind of algorithms and
like those kinds of mundane
materialistic diagnoses
but like someone's really like hi they
they did some cool
attending retreat or whatever and now
they're like
not sleeping for three days and like
super excited and incredibly creative
but it's starting to worry their family
like what is the best way to ground them
down that doesn't involve
meds you know i know a bunch of tricks
but are those the best ones i don't know
we need basic practical comparative
studies for this kind of stuff
and people run into what i would call
the dark knight like are there good
options other than meds that we could
teach
you know muggle clinicians to use and
implement and diagnose like hey you were
like
super excited three days ago and you
were seeing white energy coming up and
down your spine and your consciousness
exploded and now you're like feel like
your body is dissolving and there's like
you know you're terrified and you've
never felt anything like this before
yeah well i know what that is because
i'm used to people going through that by
the hundreds that i've talked to right
that's you know the a
p to the dark knight cycle as i would
call it that you could call it whatever
you like
but we need to agree on language that
can scale globally
and that we can come up with management
strategies that scale globally
to help these people that don't aren't
all just force medicate them essentially
with
you know atypical antipsychotics benzos
lithium and
you know you know seizure drugs
converted to mood stabilizers basically
you know not that those might not be
shown to be incredibly helpful and the
only option in certain cases but we
need to know what those criteria are and
we need to be i think a little less
liberal in the application of those
who'd be my guess
we'll see where what the science shows
i'm willing to be wrong um
but we need to do that science such that
people who want to we so we can fulfill
the promise of medical ethics
which is a basic you know intelligent
data-driven
knowledgeable conversation of risks
benefits and alternatives
so like you know such that when people
are you know start meditating what are
the chances you're going to run into
wild powerful kundalini stuff
you know as i was telling you earlier i
talked to a guy who's literally his
first meditation session
ever he had this white bolt of energy
come up his spine and hit his head and
it started expanding out
into massive like mania territory and
now he thought he was like the unified
most enlightened whatever
person and like yeah like luckily his
family and girlfriend whatever managed
to kind of ground him down i'm kind of
slightly editing the story but like you
know like
that could have gone super sideways and
luckily didn't but
but i know cases where it did go really
sideways and and
that's bad so like we need to do better
globally in terms of public
consciousness in terms of education in
schools like they're teaching meditation
in schools now
like i was a kid when i started getting
into this on weirdly small doses of
meditation
it can happen is it rare yes but is it
zero no and ethically we need to
we need to be able to handle this in
some reasonable way that isn't just
force medicating kids on powerful drugs
i was fine without meds when i was a kid
it was just weird i learned to roll with
it
you know but um and so so that's what
the eprc project is essentially about in
a nutshell
and again i think it's going to take a
few hundred million dollars at a few
hundred researchers in a few decades
because i'm willing to be honest about
how hard this is this is not going to be
easy
but that's the dream and that's what i
currently spend most of my time working
on
is trying to figure out how to find a
complete team how to find
you know all the money and how to what's
the plan like what's a
a good plan that actually hits our core
targets which are things like
the textbooks of emergency medicine
emergency psychology neurology a general
you know general practice family
practice internal medicine
um that hits the dsm and icd-11 or
whatever it is at that point when we
finally get all this done
or you know implementable in some way we
can really feel good about
um that that really impacts you know
medical board
specialty question you know exams and
core criteria and maybe even we create a
new specialty
that it specializes in this because
maybe it's the unique body of knowledge
that the other specialties like don't
have the time for and maybe this does
need to be its own integrative
meditative
you know integrative medicine board or
emergence medicine or
something um and and but i have other
friends who you know like gino you for
example a
fascinating person who who thinks
there's no way he thinks the muggles
will never get this they're going to
fight you tooth and nail to they'll die
i'm going to totally fail to integrate
this with the mainstream the apa
and everybody are going to block this
and they're just going to remain
ignorant and suck and
like be really intentional rick goblin
and map scott through
yeah no actually super inspired by rick
dublin because they started in the 80s
right and and like 30 something years
later they're in their phase
three clinical trials and stuff and i
find that kind of long-term
vision like no we're going to do this
we're going to stick it out and build an
institution
that can weather for that long and stick
it out for the long fight and
outlast entire generations because i
think this is going to take generation
education level change maybe a
generation and a half or something
and uh so and so but but that's the kind
of thing that inspires me
and that the eprc people are about it's
an amazing team right we've got people
from
you know harvard and yale and vanderbilt
and cambridge and oxford and
you know sorry if i didn't name your
amazing university that you're from but
like all these incredible people who are
like mds and phds and md phds and
neuroscientists and psychiatrists and
stuff and i think we really have a shot
at this so i'm actually super excited so
that's my shameless plug
um for the whole thing and apologies if
that was kinda long but i get excited
about this this is what i've like
this is what i pour my energy into these
days is solving this problem
because i'm just super sick of my
friends having a really hard time
when they run into my other friends
right and that's not cool we need to
change that so that's
if we think we're if we think waking up
is going to be some part of how we save
the planet and psychedelics and
meditation and spirituality or whatever
are going to be a part of that mix we
cannot have a globally adversarial
mainstream you know mental health and
medicine world that i'm sorry that's
just not cool
and we need to change that now or as
soon as we can and do it based on good
data
perfect perfect
it without a doubt without a doubt
science and the analysis of
form and the scientific method and the
clinical trial
essence has to be without a doubt
integrated into the spiritual paradigm
of consciousness awakening
has to be without a doubt you have to
marry science spirituality you have to
marry form and formlessness
you have to marry physicalism with
spirituality with
with consciousness with awareness etc
with infinity
with nothingness you have to and
i love this without a doubt this seems
like um
the architectures especially are so
relevant the architectural upgrades that
then create a
feedback mechanism so as
like rick doblin and maps have succeeded
you now see a global paradigm of
antiogens that's now taking a new
like whoa like a new popular stance
and now you'll see that more and more
with the popularization actually this
would be a good question to ask you is
what would be the ideal like you talked
about a
um a a lexicon or a language
uh nomenclature words that would be used
that are
if they're like perennial or they're
spiritually um
agnostic of specific traditions that's
the critical thing
okay yeah and then but they're also have
these words also have to be married with
science somehow mm-hmm
yes right so yeah so what would be some
of the
like and we were we just came fresh off
of our topic on maps
uh actually like making maps which
science would also want to like make
some sort of a
a nomenclature style map plugged into
its clinical trial framework
so yeah what words slash what um
maps do you feel like would be most
relevant
to try and like as we as we get more
high net worth people awakened and they
fund more things like what you're doing
what would be like a
like a first principled approach to this
being like flowered
yeah so first principles is actually
um i think that based on the the the
fact that i i
my dream is something that is as
comfortable in tehran
as it is in rio as it is in shanghai as
it is in rural alabama
which is where i am right now you know i
want something that has
that level of scalability because it has
that level of clinical neutrality to it
one of the things that a lot of my
clinicians do very well
there are some exceptions is really roll
with whatever ontologies people bring
in so this has to be as ontologically
neutral as it possibly can be which you
can kind of
argue is itself sort of an ontology
right
but it's a functional one that allows it
to scale globally regardless if you kind
of have to adopt that as a frame
right and that's what medicine does
right medicine you know teaches
you know physicians you know and you
know
you know apps and uh nurses and all
kinds of other
caregivers of all the different you know
healthcare varieties
um and mental health providers you know
psychologists psychiatrists
um you know all of the social workers
etc
that there is generally and there are
exceptions depending on the country
that i'm actually slightly jealous of
i'll get to that um that uh
where you do meet people with whatever
their ontologies are and you've really
thought about what is the essence of
this
and what i know for certain is that most
of the language i am most familiar with
and use will not scale
most of the language i use when i talk
to people about spiritual practice i
don't think it's ever going to work
i don't think it's going to get in i'm
not married to it i don't care
all i care is that the language work and
scale globally yeah that's it and if it
involves
you know every single map and every
single term i care about
not making it in i am 100 percent fine
with that as long as we help people
and i'm no attachment most of it i'm
guessing the vast majority of it won't
i'm guessing a little bit of it will
because some of the language i use is
already kind of stripped down practical
you know energy could yeah the sensation
of energy
that's pretty neutral it's not i mean
it's because it's a sensation
of energy you know or so that sensation
of vibration or of tingling or of
pulsing those are neutral terms you
could use
light is when you see light you see
light if you hear a voice you hear a
voice like
you know you could label it a
hallucination but you're hearing a voice
and actually if you look at the voice
hearing networks and
and groups and literature like there are
a lot of people here who hear voices and
they're doing fine right so you don't
have to go to the level of hallucination
because that's actually an ontological
judgment that the thing is not real
which i don't think you actually have to
do and that's where clinical medicine
kind of got itself into trouble and
really alienated the crap out of
a lot of spiritual traditions because it
started getting onto logical in ways
that were judgmental
and thus alienating right and this is
important
you know this is important to the
pentecostals you know that that go to
church five miles from where i live
as as it is as it's alienating to them
as it is to the psychonaut
you know tech brain hackers you know
even though
because they all run into the same
problem is that the clinical mainstream
made a judgment about them
and it was an anthological judgment that
i don't think they can necessarily back
up that they know for certain this is
all real or all
isn't all real you know and so i think
they kind of got a little less sciencey
than they think they are and kind of
bought into scientific materials
a little bit more than they needed to to
really come up to do practical things
like come up with good drugs which
there's a lot of cool meds out there
like
that scientific materialism really
helped with and and you know it's it's a
useful frame but it's not all
all powerful all-knowing are all helpful
when dealing with humans who have hearts
and minds and
are complicated as any good clinician
knows
right and so so in terms of the language
actually part of this
the linguistics project of communication
project that's probably gonna
you know require some big economical
councils and bringing in the big
religious traditions and say
hey what language like language can we
use
to describe this bare phenomenology that
y'all are cool with because we don't
want to piss you off
we just want to help people you know and
i want that i want the pope and
the catholic church and hierarchy to be
as comfortable with this
you know as shamans out in the amazon
somewhere i don't know if we can pull
that off but
but i would love to i would love to be
able to
to do something that was just that
descriptive and kind of technical and
precise
and then um and then have icd-10-11
codes that have that same level
of just down-to-earth neutrality that
isn't trying to pathologize anybody
but but that's actually going to be
because i think even if we get all the
science right
you know and we really because we're
actually getting some cool preliminary
results with eeg and some fmri stuff
that's been done before us and
and cool phenomenology and various
management strategies for handling
various things there's already some
science out there to build on
and a lot of cool tech the
trans-personal kids did you know which
was amazing and you know
i've got these great books by the grass
like the stormy search for the self
there's tons of cool tech in this book
you know like
thank god for you you know and the work
you did but
it's it's ontologically not neutral
enough so there's no way it scales
right and that's a pro so you know
because they did incredible stuff so
like
we've got to not make that same mistake
because i did a serious failure analysis
on like where the amazing things that
the transpersonal kids did
went wrong and that's part of it like
why did they why did they fail for
you know depending on when you think
they started if you want to go back to
you know
abraham maslow in the 60s or esl in the
70s or
all the way back to william james the
psychiatrist at harvard who read
incredible stuff and very practical
stuff and like why they totally failed
to penetrate the clinical mainstream a
lot of it is just linguistic
right people heard who are whatever word
atman and you know they were like
i don't know about no otmon and that was
it like your doa even if it's useful
tech
you know nothing against that man i use
the word all the time
but you know what i mean for sure um so
yeah
wow this has been so profound for me
because especially as we were just
talking about
the importance of taking these
child-like
analogies and visualizations and
metaphors like
light prismatically refracted ascending
like metamorphosis
and then somehow you know they're like
that
that feels like it doesn't trigger
um which is great and it feels like it
could
scale as long as there's also some sort
of of the scientific
um um literacy that's like
what is in these what is in red light
and what would be in
in orange what would be in yellow in
green
and and as it ascends but i also totally
got a heavy layer
it's still way up for sure it's the way
up um
compared to like um what would be
a word for like like you say this
language of phenomenology
like what would be a word like a mircha
eliadek
said the hierophany right so it's like a
manifestation of the sacred
but again there's like what do we do
with how do how does everest
so it almost be like materialistic as
well and the materialists are not going
to let that in a manifestation of the
sacred yeah
your doa and so i've got to have
something
yeah like no way yeah i'm sorry like i
could i could pretty much i could be i'd
be a million dollars right now that's
not going to make it
i feel i feel like i feel like there
might be something here with
um starting off with
a uh
in science would be starting off with
how
a personal contracted energy
um could be um neuroscientifically
mapped
as a uh a connectome
um that has uh
um less uh uh openness and less
universalization and less harmony
yeah funny when i look at articles in
the trans trans-personal literature
i literally want to cut out every other
word like that
like from the abstracts and i would just
if i was a uh
an editor that was just trying as hard
as i could to get this into a textbook
of emergency medicine or emergency
psychiatry
or to reach the world health
organization or to reach the
you know i would slash it i would slash
like every other word and concept and
say no
no no start again go back to the drawing
board
no like and i would be it would be
brutal and they would freaking
hate me because you know and i would
hate me like
in my own book and you know mastering
the core teachings of the buddha
mastering the core teachings of buddhist
never gonna enter the clinical
mainstream
like almost yeah i would i 80 of my book
and then like
the rest would all have to be redone
because it's not gonna work
right it's i've got too much language
i've got too much overlay i mean some of
the underlying concepts might get in
there
but the vast majority of the way i wrote
it wouldn't because it wasn't designed
for that audience
but when you start actually designing
for a clinical audience and a muggle
audience and a
an administrator audience and a health
insurance audience and a
bureaucrat audience and a national
health service policy audience
and a you know reimbursement coders
audience
like none of that's gonna fly
and because they're coming from all
these different religions all these
different backgrounds all these
different assumptions
and then you've got to do the weird
thing we do because like
you know i was practicing in rural
alabama and you know a lot of people
around here are very very religious i'm
you know in various ways that like maybe
they're not the religion that i'm as
comfortable with but i can totally meet
them where they are
pray with them be with them then move to
talk to the materialist about this and
that and you have to have that kind of
like chameleon-like capability although
i must admit i was weirdly jealous
weirdly jealous in a strange kind of way
that's almost odd to admit as a
perennialist i was reading a scientific
article
that was written in one of the
very muslim countries and it was written
for one of their
local medical journals and the first
line is like allah is the source of
all things and all things come from
allah and understanding of allah is the
key to health
and that was the first line of the or
something like that i'm kind of
paraphrasing
the first line of this article and of
course that's what they write because
in that country like medicine and the
ontology and the religion and the
government
and the public consciousness to a very
large degree are all
essentially the same page and i was i
was kind of jealous of the power of that
like they could just comfortably be
what sort of they hopefully most of them
are and aren't being forced to be that
but actually i don't know if they
honestly are that or not i'm not making
judgments
i have no idea if they would even know
um for certain
but um but it was there was you know
it's interesting like and i think the
trans-personal
people and most religious people they
love their models
they you love your models you love the
one with light and it's beautiful i
thought it was super cool when i saw it
i love my models and yet
we they're not going to make it through
you know
that's that's heavy baggage that's not
going to make it through the sieve or
whatever
of this goal and that's why nobody's
been willing to give up enough of their
ontologies to to do this
i see i see so okay okay so take
i do so take me through what it's like
where you have um
the
scientific consensus that there's
a an individual that feels
contracted energy and it's next to an
individual that feels
open and liberated right now
psychometrically we can
view this as um the the psychometric
trait openness
is one of those you know again that's a
psychometric trait based on like
filling in um an analysis that's
subjective of one's own
um so then if you take things like
biomarkers that are like your
connectomix so would you say that like
connectomic
biomarkers might be one of the
like forefront ways to objectify
what is like a contracted versus a
universalized energy
well actually i would love to do the
science on that and be able to give you
better because the scientist in me now
is coming out because you've kind of i'm
suddenly got into clinical scientist
mode
which may be boring for some people i
apologize but it's suddenly like that's
how i'm thinking
and when i think about that so one of
the big dreams of the eprc
yet again another shameless plug for a
big charity ask
for a big non-profit thing we want to
build is called the emergence research
center
and what we want to do in the emergence
research center is actually bring in as
many traditions
we'll be kind enough to grace our our
our door with their presence
and to bring them in and to have fmri
and
high density eeg and epigenetic and wet
lab you know full
biomarker measurement capabilities and
you know ai on qualitative and
quantitative
data analysis and full biomarkers and
full monitoring of these people for
affect for valence
for mood and then the capab and then
enough resources to actually follow
these people up long stream
after they leave whatever intense
retreat or spiritual or meditative or
hot yoga or whatever experience they did
you know
and to be able to see to catch these
experiences in real time
to be able to measure someone who is
feeling some contracted
trauma thing with a story that then
releases and be able to measure that
as much as we can possibly measure that
which i think will also involve
need to involve body electrodes and
maybe even like neuromuscular sampling
like to see if there's actually receptor
changes or you know
are we going to have to put you know
actually do nerve conduction studies on
some of these people and see if there is
actually free or flow of
whatever that's going to be painful but
like that's the kind of science
i want to do and dream of and the team
wants to do adriba and dr katie devaney
dreams of running it and uh that's i
think you know 50-ish million dollars to
get a really good start on that
and that's not that actually that much
money as biomedical research goes like
just to bring a single drug to market is
like two point something billion now two
point six or eight billion
right for a single drug that might just
be some copycat [ __ ] that doesn't
really add to our clinical arsenal of
utility
and so like you know uh just you know
give us a
give us a tenth of that we could do a
lot you know and so that's actually
before so before i answer that question
yeah maybe
but now what i dream of is like going
out of the realm of speculation
let's just freaking do this let's answer
these questions that people have been
kicking around for decades
and we're no closer to answer than
really at that ra really hard science
level
and i would love to know and actually
sell an addisoi who actually
did a lot of stuff with connectome
harmonix is in the eprc
as is quentin fredericks and um you know
with quality
the quality of research there are a
number of quality research members
that are you know eprc members and um i
was just talking with them
actually it was yesterday two days ago
when we were talking to um
quintet is two days ago actually we were
talking about an eeg study that i had
done that was looking at the various
ways the brain connects or disconnects
and actually just making sure we spec
out the harvard i'm going to be involved
in two meditator and a scanner studies
at harvard martinez imaging center
mclean um
hospital in the boston cambridge area
actually looking at some of the stuff
and we were just making sure we had we
that we spec out the scans
to get the connectome harmonics analyses
done
on as i shift through various meditative
states and then we have other talented
meditators come in and shift through
something like those same states
and because you know i know how to
replicate really tense states and then
like dissolve them because i can do that
like that's the kind of stuff we could
look at
and then if you could catch people doing
it de nova where it's not kind of
simulated but it's actually happening to
them
in real time that's how we're going to
get those answers and until we build
those kinds of research capabilities
it's all just going to be talk
and i'm kind of sick of that like let's
fricken do it you know if we actually
care about this stuff and helping people
let's figure it out and and like for all
these people for their kids let's create
like
hey all like shameless plug to rich
people sorry
like if you want your kids to grow up in
a world where we actually understand
this stuff well and your parents and
your family and yourselves and your own
spiritual journeys and your own brain
hacking and
ayahuasca quests and five meow journeys
and whatever it is and
and cool things you're doing like it
would be great if we could help you to
do that better help us do the science
you know this is all
not-for-profit science this is not with
any industrial or
you know corporate or for-profit agenda
we just want to help
people and this needs to be done because
every single person on the team knows
that they're there for themself that's
why they gathered they
they've all experienced something on
this path that's that the clinical
mainstream
would not relate to skillfully and and
so
we're inspired and and just fund us to
do it
and that's kind of the bottom line and
the rest is all speculation and talk
perfect so we take this like big picture
visualization with this there's like six
to ten trillion dollars that's currently
locked up in high net with individuals
and families
and we also enable them to see that it's
not only going to benefit themselves and
their families their kids
their community the world at large yeah
um it's
it's also what is precisely going to
synthesize science spirituality it's
going to create
more of a of the planet focused on the
sustainable development goals and the
things that actually matter around the
planet as well as consciousness and
metaphysics
yeah and so i really like the
visualization of taking like the
connectomix the ekg
the microbiome i like sort of the suite
of analysis and then having like a
thousand people
that are like you and me frank etc
go in that are able to let's say that
we're anchoring the awakened state and
then you have sort of
mainstream people that feel lots of
stress lots of anxiety lots of
depression
lots of non-harmonic biometrics
and then map a thousand of those and
then you take like a meta pattern of the
data of the awakened state versus the
stress state and then you find what is
most
relevant to extract as the key
biomarkers from both of those
and then so it's that kind of a
scientific analysis that would have to
be done
yeah and so we're talking like 50
million dollars just to be able to do
stuff like
this just to really get into the range
it could run 100 sorry if i if 50s may
be too low but
it's going to be a bunch of money to
have a proper team because you need
where most of the neurosciences kind of
sucked is actually in the
microphenomenology they may have
measured gigabytes of data on the person
but actually asked very few questions in
real time about the what their actual
experience was
i think this is what's why most of the
you know meditator and scanner studies
are actually not that good so i'm being
a little critical of my colleagues but
we you know i've been in studies that
have been guilty of the same thing so
but like and then to follow these people
up to see what their experiences lead to
in terms of practical outcomes
like that takes big teams and do
qualitative data analysis take
big teams and it's expensive it's
tedious i think we need some ai that
could do a lot with that
with valence analysis and other things
but also actually one of the things
we're dreaming of is what we call the
big data project
i actually think the vast majority of
the data is actually already there
in the form of google and twitter and
facebook
and instagram and the big social media
data sets
and cambridge analytica and um you know
these people have access
because now we have you know two plus
billion people or whatever for
hour for many years ten or something
years they've been plugged in
where we know what techniques they
looked at we know what retreats they
went on and we know what books they were
reading we knew what youtube videos they
were watching we knew if they were going
to yoga classes
we we know all or they know not we it's
not me actually
they know at the moment but globally
that knowledge and data exists
and then we know like hey they went on
this meditation retreat they took the
psychedelic they tweeted to their
friends this and then
like you know three days later they were
suddenly up at four in the morning
when they're never up at four in the
morning typist typing twice as fast as
they usually do
what the hell is kundalini you know and
then like three weeks later
they're reading you know they're typing
what are the side effects of seroquel
you know and like we could you know and
then
like what helped them and how did they
do and like what techniques did they run
into when they started their spiritual
quest
and what percent killed themselves and
what percent thrive became incredible
you know world-changing entrepreneurs
and what people you know dwelt in their
cubicles better and what people had
better health
outcomes and what people cost the health
insurance policies less and the national
health systems less and
what techniques led to them costing more
and what techniques led to people
flipping out or getting divorced or
becoming incredibly loving compassionate
humans
i think that data is already there and
literally we just need to analyze it
want to save us a whole lot of time get
us access to that data
and get us the 20 or 30 million dollars
or whatever it would take to analyze it
well i don't know what that would cost
but it would i think it would save us
10x um and and
probably save us like two or three
decades of having to do all the tedious
like
you know and we still need to do some of
that we still need controlled trials
but that is a massive amount of day that
could probably save us a staggering
amount of time
and actually just get us really good
practical real world already tried in
the field recommendations of live human
studies of the
because the people have already done the
experiments for themselves they've
already sought they've already found
it led to whatever outcomes it did and i
think there's enough data there
despite all the noise you could still
sort out a lot of signal with good data
processing
so if you as the listening person happen
to be someone who has access to any of
that
let us know we would be happy to talk
with you and help you with those
analyses
to make this whole project a lot faster
another shameless plug for the eprc
wow sorry if i download pretty fast
if you're listening to this another
language by the way i apologize i know i
talk fast i'm sorry i get excited it's
part of my pathology and hopefully a
little bit of charm
so yeah your map
about how to best execute this is really
strong
and i love how anchored it is in the
mainstream
scientific business data collection
paradigm and how because that's that's
the quickest way
in and also i love how you see it from
being able to work with a lot of the
funding sources
that can accelerate this
i'm a huge huge fan of this and
i feel like everything that i've been
working on
in the last especially about seven
or so months ago what i was publishing
around
the synthesis of science of spirituality
and getting it as quickly as possible
into the mainstream
it had a lot to do with this data fusion
of the connectome the ekg the microbiome
and then extracting out a meta pattern
of a thousand very awaken people versus
a thousand people that are suffering
depressed
anxious etc sure right yeah and so
um i feel like you are doing exactly
what i was excited about and writing
about and trying to visualize and so
now it's even easier for me to figure
out how to pull
resources into that we've got the team
already we've got the plan like we just
at this point we really just need the
cash like
yeah we have enough to do all of that
that's i've already talked to
geneticists at the cdc and
and you know senior geneticists at johns
hopkins and
we've got microbiologists we've we've
got that
um we've got people who have already
done epigenetic data stuff i mean
yeah like that's great i already have
people that are
that i'm that are coming up that i feel
like would
want to that are involved in the high
net worth space that would want to
fuel this because of that level of um
serious readiness and a team-ness
and white paper-ness and that those
variables
um visionariness so um that's great
because i
i will uh let's see where a couple of
those intros can go off the bat and then
where
where they will funnel beyond that
because
i i know that there are people that are
listening right now that have
connections to people
like what we're describing and um you
can go to
dan's website and grab his email and
make an introduction as well
and because this is it i mean this is
our
this is our gateway to mainstream and
the accelerated
path to it rather than the sort of hey
let's uh let's hands off relax in the
awakening
and ask people away as people somehow
stumble upon it themselves they'll come
to us
versus how do we go in with the
architectural
understanding of how to merge science
spirituality and make it
clinically neutral and ontologically
neutral
and to ramp things up um that's sort of
like a fanning the flame uh rather
approach and
and i like that approach and i feel like
it really resonates with people
so you are you are it in terms of that
big
pillar for us i love that yeah i'm
sick of playing around and so it's like
just and it's amazing how many people
you just tell them that and they're like
of course
and that they just join and they're like
hell yeah like it's something that's
needed to happen and
people have tried things like this it's
not like people haven't tried
phenomenological approaches they have or
neuroscience approaches
they have there's lots but but um if
there's an equivalent dream that is
quite as big
and bold and brash and dedicated to
hitting
the hard tedious targets that i think
most people just like throw up their
hands and go uh
you know like getting board questions
into board question exams
and getting it into the core curricula
of various medical specialties
and you know petitioning you know the
american you know
board of medical specialties or the the
different specialty boards
or um you know or changing billing codes
that's the kind of tedium most people
don't want to do but it's going to take
that and so we're
dedicated to the grinding painful
institution
building and changing tedium as well
like not just the cool flashy findings
no we're we want to find the money to
change the bureaucracies
at that core functional day-to-day
paperwork
kind of level right which sucks and is
horrible
and yet desperately needs to happen and
that's what we've decided to do
so if you're interested in a long
painfully expensive
project that will involve a lot of tdm
and bureaucracy and hard targets and
hard conversations and
hard lobbying and all that please talk
to us but i think that's what it's going
to take
anything else i think is just it's fun
and
flashy but i don't think it's real yeah
i'm really excited for one specific
introduction
for this for you um because
the the very nature of this this person
is so aligned with what is unfolding
but they're they're the exact essence of
how do i put it into a place that's
trusted that's actually gonna do it
which is basically the number one
question that these
high net worth families have is um
how do we find what is actually going to
do it in a trusted way
yeah that's what i found is is the key
yeah well i've got a
you know i spent um so we spent about a
year building the eprc white paper and
plan
and then spent most of the last eight
months or so
building the container to hold the cash
to get to just get down to brass tacks
um we have an impressive board we have
some very uh
well built diligent bylaws and
procedures we have
you know an accountant and auditing
and all of that stuff that we've just
gotten on board we have
you know um developing very uh
reasonable grant allocation and
monitoring policies and stuff and so
we've really gone out of our way to
build the kind of structure
that can responsibly hold that kind of
money and keep it and be a
responsible custodian of it and
distributor of it and monitor
what we're doing and we're very
transparent about what our plan is a lot
of these organizations like
have sort of secret plans or big teams
but you can't really figure out what
they're going to do
you can read our whole freaking long
tedious white paper
and figure out exactly what we're going
to do and what it costs and why we think
it costs that
it's not you know it's in there and and
there are also places where the plan
needs a few more people and we're honest
about that like where we like we don't
have enough
medical anthropologists yet we need them
to make sure that we go in
understanding the needs of all needs of
all the involved tribes like what what
does the apa need to let us in what does
the world health organization need to
let us in we have some pretty good ideas
we've had some preliminary conversations
um but
yeah like some of that really needs to
be done very thoughtfully and with a lot
of nuance
what do insurance companies need you
know like
what does the pharmaceutical industry
need to play nicely with this stuff
like that's important and so yeah like
these are the kinds of hard questions
that
that we have tremendous respect for all
of these groups
and they're all trying to help in their
way we're willing to give them the
benefit of the doubt as well as
be appropriately wary you know trust but
verify kind of thing
but um yeah so like uh also so if you're
if you look at the eprc white paper and
you're like i have a skill or a talent
that you don't have a name under that
slot and you say these people are needed
please get in touch with us as well
because i think we've got about 70 of
the i think 300 or so people we're going
to need to do this
and so um we've also gotten to the phase
where
if we were holding more cash i think
there are more people who would then
turn more attention our way just to be
as a blatant plug of practicalities
um yeah
and all these links are found in the bio
below
so you can find the eprc you can find
e-benefactors
you can also find dan's website you can
find his book
and if you have any questions about any
of this i would love to talk with you
perfect
here's what i think that we'll do also
is um
one of the big things that's come up for
me
is also shifting us away
from what is the
the island model towards the
cohesive model i like the
way of of funneling
also people around the world that are
doing this
into a like a best practices
unit um that's cohesive around
synthesizing science spirituality and
getting it into the mainstream
scientific
architecture yeah so that's another way
of
synthesizing so what i what i feel like
i know
where i feel like where i want to
um to take our exploration
in terms of like what we can do next um
introduction wise and how that could
funnel into the success of this
and then what i feel like we could do
also
conversationally is maybe
maybe like once a once a quarter
or what not we can revisit because
something that we were talking about
with
um with frank and with other people is
doing this
um like quarterly on a on a
cadence where we're undergoing a process
of
of what would be the ideal
way to like we were talking about with
that met like the meta pattern of a
thousand people that have experienced
some sort of awakening versus
thousand that are still in some
depressive contracted state and getting
a biometric meta pattern and whatnot
and um and just revisiting where we're
at with the progress and updating people
around that while we're simultaneously
dynamically
iterating what is what is optimal um
yeah so that's another thing to to
explore together
and yeah that sounds like tremendous fun
i'd be way up for that
[ __ ] yeah awesome awesome do you feel
like the intention is
closing for the for the show that felt
like a really good wrapping up place if
that feels good to you
did that feel good may have been
different topics than you were thinking
about talking about but was that did
that work was it all right
it was so perfect it was just
indescribably perfect
that was awesome thank you and i really
appreciate the opportunity and your
enthusiasm and interest in getting this
out there
it's it's yeah yeah much gratitude
me too me too because you're the you're
the embodied
version of what people so
badly want to happen but don't know how
to
do the hard work to get it into the
science and the engineering and the
mainstream architectures
and so let's funnel that energy
more into you and the team and and the
white paper and
and the clinical trials and the
nomenclature and all of that good stuff
and the proper high net worth funding
and all this stuff so
let's get that let's get that rolling
deeper and i feel like a lot of our
our audience got the chance to take away
some of the initial conversation around
um
just awakening in general and what it's
like to become unfreeze more of that
will and become more sovereign but also
we went into the
beauty of the highest level metaphysical
abstraction
but then we also were like how do we do
this in mainstream society today
and so we really navigated a beautiful
mosaic and
that's what i love about the interviews
most of all is
that specific aspect to it so thank you
for
also being able to anchor it in which is
exactly what we need
thanks that was awesome okay great yeah
bye
yeah i'll let's let's i'll wrap the show
and then
one sec dan let me wrap the show and
i'll end the broadcast we'll stay in the
studio for a moment
thanks everyone for tuning in we love
you so much really grateful
we would love we would love for you to
check out the links in the bio below
again all of dan's links are down there
go and check them out
and support in whatever ways you can and
also like the video helps the algorithm
comment below with your thoughts we
would love to hear from you on some of
your thoughts around the episode
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet and also share the video if you feel
like
there were segments in here that were
really powerful share it with your
friends family
etc online and
that is all again infinite love thanks
for tuning in
and thanks again dan and i'll go ahead
and end it we'll stay in the studio
bye everyone
you